[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you, Meredith, for
covering so much of what I'm
going to talk about today.
So let's--
- Oh, no.
I was try--
- No, no, in a very great way.
And just for being such
a generous introducer.
Hannah Arendt has this phrase,
thinking without banisters.
And it's often
used metaphorically
to mean that you have to
think on your own, that
is you have to think
without others behind you
and think for yourself.
But in a material sense,
we all know that thinking
does require banisters.
It requires a lot of support.
And I just want to start
today by saying how grateful I
am to the Radcliffe
Institute for giving me
all these banisters
for this year
to really think to take
a break from teaching
to try some stuff out.
So I'll be eternally grateful.
My project this
year and what I'm
looking at at the
Radcliffe Institute
is legal naturalization.
And what I'm interested
in about naturalization
is that it's the only
way that a person, who's
not linked to a state
by birth or dissent,
can be granted
citizenship within it.
And at the outset, if it
wasn't clear from Meredith's
introduction, I should say I'm
not a lawyer so don't ask me
for legal advice after this.
And I'm not a historian.
I'm a literary and
critical theorist.
And I say that because I'm
not trying to exonerate myself
from any relevance or
relationship to truth
but because the way I approach
naturalization and immigration,
in general, is different from
how legal historian may choose
to go about looking at it.
As a critical
theorist, I'm really
drawn to the fictional
and rhetorical forms
of laws and rights.
And I also look for
the history of law
beyond its expression in law
itself for positive mystic law.
So in the past, I've written
about human rights quite a bit
and their basis in the
abstract principle of humanity.
And before humanity, it
was the abstract principle
of nature, human nature.
For this new project, I'm
looking more at naturalization
and the coincidence
that it developed
as a legal process
at the same time
that the novel was
developing in England.
Though just as
naturalization was
becoming a matter of
public debate in England,
the novel is a new genre--
long prose fiction--
was becoming
a new form of literature.
And I think we can learn a lot
about both law and literature
from looking at these
two things together.
So today, my talk is going
to be in three parts.
I'm going to review the book
that I co-authored on The Right
to Have Rights, which
Meredith mentioned,
because it's really
this project and where
it left me that inspired
me to start digging
into naturalization.
So I'll just rehearse
that a little bit more.
Then I'm going to talk about
the history of naturalization
and my interest in it.
And in the third part,
which is, in many ways,
still under a lot of
active construction,
I'm going to turn to
the history of the novel
as a way to look at
naturalization differently.
OK, so part 1.
In January, I published
with the legal historian,
a political scientist
and an activist,
a book called The
Right to Have Rights.
Here it is.
It's quite green.
[LAUGHS] You won't miss it.
And the book offered a very,
very intensely close reading
of Hannah Arendt's phrase,
the right to have rights.
In fact, each author,
we broke the phrase down
into four parts, and
each of us took a part.
And I was responsible for
writing about the first right
in the phrase.
And the phrase, the
right to have rights
grows out of Arendt's experience
as a stateless refugee.
In 1933, she flees
Nazi Germany for Paris.
And two years later, she
and other German Jews
effectively lose their
citizenship in Germany.
In France, she's interned as
an enemy national in a camp.
But she is able
to luckily escape
when the Germans occupy France.
There's a bit of some
confusion, and she gets out.
And she makes an appeal while
in the unoccupied part of France
to some US diplomats.
However, the US State
Department at the time
is actively discouraging
giving visas
to German Jews or any
refugees for that matter.
But through a combination
of luck and quick thinking
and a person in the US
State Department, who's
prepared to defy the
orders of superiors,
she is able to secure a
Nansen passport, a French exit
visa, a Spanish and Portuguese
transit visa, and a US
emergency visa.
It's lot of visas.
In 1941, she's given
asylum in the US.
And in 1951, she's
naturalized as a US citizen.
In the same year as her
naturalization, 1951,
she publishes the origins
of totalitarianism,
which is her first
English language book.
And you may have heard it
after the election in 2016.
It became something
of a mysterious best
seller where a lot of
people were buying it,
hoping for answers.
In one of the book's
central chapters,
such as the chapter in which the
right to have rights appears,
she reflects on
what her experience
as a stateless
refugee taught her
about the ways in
which individuals
come to gain and lose rights.
The Universal Declaration
of Human Rights
proclaims that human
rights have rights simply
by the virtue of being human.
But Arendt knew, first hand,
that in order to have rights,
individuals must be more
than simply human beings.
They must, she
insisted, be members
of a political community.
Only as a citizen of
a nation state can
a person enjoy legally
protected rights--
education, to work, to health
care, to culture, and so on.
And so Arendt
declared that there
must be something
called the right
to have rights before we can
have any other kinds of rights.
And here's how it appears.
I'll show you.
This is probably the only text.
I'll have up here
for you tonight.
But it's really important.
And we spent a lot of
time on it in the book.
I'll read it to you.
We became aware of the existence
of a right to have rights.
And that means to
live in a framework
where one is judged according
to actions and opinions
and a right to belong to some
kind of organized community
only when there suddenly emerged
millions of people who had lost
and could not regain
these rights because
of the new global
political situation.
And in my work on the book,
one of the things I do
is I emphasize that this
is a really strange right.
And it's because
of its temporality.
It's a right that
comes into existence.
We become aware of it only
when it's already disappeared.
And I end up calling
the right to have
rights what I call post right.
It's the right that
makes itself known only
when the possibility of its
arrival has already gone.
And I'm still looking for really
great Latin term or something
to describe this some
kind of rhetorical term.
So if anybody has any
ideas, I'd love to know.
So it's less of a right
that can be used or employed
than a eulogy for a right
that no longer exists.
It's not something
we can stage or argue
for in Arendt's thinking.
It's something that
we discover as lost,
and that's its tragedy.
What Arendt wanted to
show is that even when
someone performs a right to have
rights by showing up in public
and making a demand
for it, as we've all
seen in the news
in multiple places,
there still needs to be a
nation state to recognize it.
I'll offer you a brief
example that I talk
about a little bit in the book.
In 2014, residents
of Detroit, Michigan
filed a lawsuit
against the city,
because it had shut off the
running water of some residents
who couldn't afford to
pay their water bills.
And the judge ruled against the
residents, saying that, quote,
"water is a necessary
ingredient to sustaining life,
but there's no enforceable
right to water."
So in response, the residents
called on the United Nations.
And they wanted to claim that
their right to water in Detroit
was a human right.
So Arendt, I think,
would, undoubtedly,
had she been alive--
by the way, the anniversary
of her death is yesterday--
I think she would have
recognized the polemical value
of this move.
It's a shaming mechanism.
But while the claims
certainly garnered
a lot of media
publicity, it doesn't
have the force to produce a
right to water under US law.
The appeal to human
rights in this case
merely reinforced the
lack of enforceable right
in the civic national context.
The United Nations could
make, quote, "recommendations"
and, quote, "do a
fact finding mission."
But it couldn't validate the
right of a claim to water.
There's no guarantee that a
performative claim to right
will be validated, especially,
if the community that a rights
claimant seeks entrance into
the very community that's
responsible for
its loss of rights.
And that's, of course,
something that Arendt
knew deeply from her experience
as a subject of the Nuremberg
laws, which made all Jews
like herself of alien blood.
After fleeing the
detention center in France,
Arendt doesn't go
back to Germany
to make a performative claim
of her right to have rights.
No, she escapes to America.
The country of her
birth, the community
on which she might stake
a claim of membership,
was actively the country
that didn't want her there.
And so Arendt's point--
and she goes on
to make this point
in a very detailed
and lengthy way--
is that there's no universal
right to citizenship.
There's only two loopholes
that she identifies
in her writing for
a stateless refugee
to gain citizenship or at least
the attention of the nation
state.
One is they can commit a crime.
Getting yourself
arrested, she said,
is one of at least
one way of getting
acknowledged by the state.
The other loophole is that a
stateless person or a refugee
can somehow become famous.
And this is Mamoudou Gassama.
He was formerly an
undocumented migrant in France.
And this past summer, he
was granted citizenship
from the French
government after he
scaled a building to rescue
a small child from falling.
It is true, says Arendt, that
the chances of a famous refugee
are improved just
as a dog with a name
has a better chance to survive
than a stray dog who is just
a dog in general.
So that's what I finished.
[LAUGHS] And it left me in
a pretty pessimistic place.
And my conclusion, I had
to note that at the time
of her writing, Arendt
thought that America
was the one hopeful place.
And she said that America
was always a place that
welcomed its newcomers.
But I think we have reason
to be suspicious of her place
of hope.
And so it was at
this moment that I
decided that I wanted to look at
naturalization and its history,
because it seemed
to offer something
more concrete than abstract
principles of human right.
With naturalization, we can see
how, historically, citizenship
has been created for foreigners.
And I actually got the idea.
And I didn't quite
know it at the time
from Arendt herself, who
has this throwaway line
in the origins of
totalitarianism.
She says that unlike
their happier predecessors
in the religious wars, the
refugees after World War II
could be welcomed nowhere
and assimilated nowhere.
So one of my first
questions was, well,
who are these happier refugees?
And what was so different
about immigration
in the late 17th
and 18th centuries?
On what basis were all of
these refugees received
and integrated in a time before,
quote, unquote, "human rights?"
So I began to explore.
I spent some time
at the archives
at the Clark Library at UCLA
and the glorious Huntington
Library in Los Angeles.
And I've done quite
a bit of digging
with the help of three
incredible research
assistants--
Tamara, Jessica, and Amanda--
just got Amanda.
Thank you.
They're not here
tonight, but I really
appreciate it, because
it's been a lot of work.
And we've been digging around
in old musty law books,
trying to figure out what
this history might look like.
And I'll tell you the
story so far as I'm
constructing it for myself.
Prior to the Napoleonic
period, nationality
was decided by the feudal
tradition of jus soli.
Now, jus soli dates back
to a medieval system
in which a subject
owes undying allegiance
to the monarch under
whom they're born.
And it gets this tradition,
this feudal tradition,
gets refined into English
common law following
this important legal case
called Calvin's Case--
1608.
And in this case, the
court had to decide
whether a young Scottish child
named Robert Calvin whether he
had the right to inherit
a family estate in London.
That was the case.
And the court did decide
that Robert Calvin did
have the right to
inherit the estate,
because at the
time of his birth,
the English King sovereignty
had extended to Scotland.
So Calvin's Case made
the all-important ruling
that is detectable in
American nationality law today
that a person's membership
in a national community
is determined by the
place of their birth.
And you might be
interested to know
that jus soli or birthright
citizenship, as it's sometimes
called, is still the dominant
principle of citizenship
in the United States
and in Canada.
There's scarcely anywhere
else in the world.
Even England, who's
responsible for the idea
or tradition of
jus soli, no longer
retains it as a principle.
But in addition to making
this important ruling
about birthright
citizenship, Calvin's Case
also addressed how
nonsubjects, namely the Scots,
could be made into
subjects in law.
And so that ruling
really was interested.
Now, OK, what do we
do with the Scots?
How do we make them
English subjects?
But over the course
of the century,
the 17th but especially into
the 18th century, that debate
about naturalization
would take on more people
from different
backgrounds and places.
And the biggest one happened
in 1685 when Louis XIV,
he revokes the Edict of Nantes.
Protestants were
living in Catholic--
France.
And so hundreds of thousands--
it's an enormous scale--
of Protestants
had to flee France
at the risk of being violently
converted to Catholicism.
They went all over the place.
Many of them fled to the
Netherlands, Switzerland,
Wales.
And an estimated
50,000 of what were
known as the Huguenots
came to England
and which is to this
day, one of the largest
immigrations of a single
ethnic community into England.
So that's around 1685.
And it's these refugees, who
Arendt refers to as happier.
And in many ways, they were
considered what we might today
call model immigrants.
They were highly
skilled craftspeople.
And they worked
primarily as weavers.
And they were Protestants.
So the English quite liked them.
And they decided
that they were going
to try and use naturalization
to entice more of them
to come over.
And this is when
in 1709, parliament
invents what's called the
general naturalization act.
And basically this
is an act that
says, any foreign person
who's willing to swear
an oath of allegiance
to the English crown
take sacrament in the Church
of England, pay one shilling.
Then they would be,
quote, "as if they
were born in this kingdom."
So they wanted the
Huguenots to come.
But trouble begins the same
year that the naturalization act
is passed.
13,000 immigrants from the Rhine
region of Northwest Germany
enter England.
And these German migrants were
dubbed, the poor Palatines.
This is a wood cut from 1709.
I'm sorry about the quality.
But I think it may be one
of the first representations
of a modern refugee camp.
The Palatines formed a
camp outside of London.
It was crowded.
It was full of disease.
They were dependent a lot upon
charity from church groups
and so on.
The reason the Palatines
came to England
is not quite clear
to historians.
Some people argue that they also
faced religious persecution.
Others suggest that they
were fleeing the effects
of a really cold hard winter.
They were mainly farmers.
What is clear-- we don't
know why they came exactly,
or there's multiple
interpretations
is that they did not
receive a warm welcome.
The Tory critics liken
them to the plague.
And, eventually, they were
shipped off to America
where many of them
died en route.
And I nearly jumped
out of my skin.
I'm sorry for the
quality of this.
But I found this
in a old newspaper
at the Clark Library, which was
a table, that basically breaks
down how many of them died
en route and how many of them
arrived--
sort of odd way of accounting.
I can't really in the frame,
well, I have with you.
I can't really do justice to
the history of naturalization
or to these particular
refugee groups.
But I want to emphasize
a few points as they
are coming clear to me today.
One, naturalization
in the 18th century
is not about the
freedom to settle.
Before the 19th century--
and this is really important--
England was a country
of open borders.
It didn't regulate
who could come.
how long you can stay.
But if you did
come, and you wanted
to receive some positive
benefits, such as the right
to purchase property or to pass
down some effects to an heir,
then you had to be naturalized.
So it was something-- it was a
bonus, basically, a very nice
bonus.
And it also allowed you to
sit in government offices.
Naturalization in
the 18th century
is all about property, not
about political rights.
The question of
nationality in this period
is all about whether a
foreign-born son can inherit
from an English
father or vice versa,
whether an English son can
inherit from a foreign father.
This is the whole question
of the problem for jurists.
Lastly and most
importantly for me,
naturalization in
the period doesn't
promise to make a foreigner the
same as a natural-born subject.
It's not a declaration of a
primordial natural right, such
as you start to see in the
1789 Declaration of Rights
of Man and Citizen, which
launched the French Revolution.
And unlike the 20th century
concept of naturalization,
there's no expectation that
a naturalized foreigner
will speak the same
language, engage
in the same national
customs, or even become
more English over time.
And, today, I mean,
some of you may not
know what it requires to
be naturalized in America.
You have to have a green card.
And you have to have a
green card for five years.
And you have to have
live in the United States
continuously for that period.
You have to read,
write, and speak
English, have a basic
understanding of civics
and government, be, quote,
"of sound moral character,"
and six, demonstrate an
attachment to the ideals
of the US Constitution.
So to arrive at
naturalization today
is to arrive fully realized with
secure bonds and attachments.
There's a huge contrast from
early naturalization, which
was just a legal design to
settle matters of property
rather than create some sort
of sense of national inclusion
and belonging.
The radicalness of this
early naturalization stuff,
it can't really be overstated.
The general naturalization
act effectively
moved the location
of nationality
from a prior basis
and birthright
to qualities of faith,
finance, and language.
And it was precisely the
kind of rhetorical basis
of the act, the idea
that it could just
produce subjects, who just swore
an oath, that produced really
strong opposition from
conservative critics, who
interpreted the act to mean
that anyone could just become
an English person in language.
This is something I
found in the archive.
It was a poem.
Now, a lot of times
in the period, poetry
was used to disseminate
political opinions.
It was designed to
manipulate opinion
against the naturalization
act, and it's quite long.
But the gist of it
is that the refugees
are likened to canary birds
that were brought over
by Spanish sailors
in the 17th century.
And the author argues that
these canary birds are going
to disturb the English utopia.
So it's like a very elaborate
extended metaphor about birds.
But you get the idea.
But for all of the
radicalness I just
spoke up about
naturalization, it
was a really limited form too.
It was really
designed to attract
a select group of migrants.
Over the course of
the 18th century,
it was going to face challenges
from other people who
are perceived as threats--
Jews, Catholics, and free
blacks dubbed the black poor.
The Jewish
Naturalization of 1753
was narrowly passed by
the Whigs in Parliament
and then swiftly repealed.
And it produced an enormous
wave of anti-Semitism
in the country.
And here's a kind of
satirical swipe at critics
of Jewish naturalization.
You see a bunch of
kingly people, who
are frightened at a, quote,
"nasty, great, ugly Jew
bill," which is really this
rolled up scroll on the floor.
It was a depiction of the
threat that supposedly
this legal maneuver would have.
I'm actively researching
a little bit more
right now about
the black poor, who
were a combination
of former slaves
and black sailors from
America, who were settled
in a colony in Sierra Leone.
Because they were
unwanted in London,
so they were lured away to this
new colony with the promise
that they would be
given citizenship
there and protection
from the royal army.
This is similar to what England
did with the Palatines--
shift the problem away rather
than develop a legal design
to integrate people
in England itself.
So given all of these
failures in the 18th century
and then more seismically
after World War II
where naturalization is all
but suspended for refugees.
It may seem odd that
I'm actually even
interested in this history.
But even though
naturalization only
affected a small
number of migrants,
it opened up a public
debate about who
could be received and granted
privileges in the nation.
In this debate, as I'm going
to try and suggest to you now,
survives and is transformed
by the fiction that's
running alongside of it.
The refugee movements in the
18th century and 17th century,
they're managed
through naturalization.
In fact, it could be
argued that naturalization
is invented to manage them.
But at the same time
that naturalization
is devising new rules
about national inclusion,
the novel's developing
as a new genre.
The novel gets its name, novel,
because it was new at the time.
And one of the things
that made it so new
is that it introduced
all kinds of new subjects
into literature--
servant girls, slaves orphans,
middle class businessmen--
just about anybody who, under
classical rules of genre,
especially of tragedy,
would never be considered
as subject of literature.
So I'm interested in the
novel and naturalization
in one sense, because
they're both forms that
create new subjects who had
previously been unrecognized.
Right, so there's just
that basic parallel.
But, in fact, as I've been
researching this project,
I've learned more
about law from novels
sometimes than from
archival materials.
And I think that maybe
because the novel
is a more sustained
space of imagination.
So it's a place where
people can really
experiment with ideas,
especially, of identity
and connection in ways
that are sort of limited
in newspaper debates.
And the other reason
I'm interested in
is that if you just
study naturalization
as a legal history,
you're going to be
confined to the Protestants,
mainly the Huguenots.
But the novel when it
takes up naturalization,
it introduces the
topic and extends it
into empire to
discussions of race.
Ideas that if you strictly just
stick to the archival materials
and naturalization,
you're likely to miss.
So I'm not the first
person, of course,
to think that the novel has
particular political importance
in the 18th century.
Many incredible
scholars have argued
that the 18th century novel
and the 19th century novel
is a handmade into the
emergence of the nation state,
and that the novel helped
forge a sense of what it meant
to be an English Protestant.
Edward Said and
Benedict Anderson
are probably the two
most important examples.
Said argued in culture
and imperialism
that the novel narrated the
English Imperial Project.
And he argued that the novel
was a concretely historical
narrative.
And that you could learn a lot
about empire and colonialism
from studying it.
Benedict Anderson had similar
ideas but differently.
In his very famous book,
Imagined Communities,
he argued that the novel
became a form where individuals
could come to
understand themselves
as members of collective.
And it did that by mimicking the
structure of a clearly bordered
national community.
I'm not here to disagree
with those theories.
But one thing I have noticed
is that after reading so much
about naturalization
and rereading so many
of these seminal
novels, I've come
to see that the
novel was thinking
about the borders
of national identity
just as much as it was
allegedly defining them.
Novelists in the period
were experimenting with ways
to expand the possibilities
and naturalization, especially,
after the repeal of the
general naturalization act
and then later after the repeal
of the Jewish Naturalization
Act.
And it's extraordinary
to me how many
novels that we've long read
is conservative or is vested
in deep nationalisms are
actually engaging questions
about naturalization
that if you understand
a little bit about the law,
you can begin to notice.
I'm going to give
three examples.
And I'm picking
them, essentially,
because these are popular
18th century novels that
have been read as providing
kind of nativist origin stories
for the English nation.
First one, Robinson
Crusoe, published
by Daniel Defoe in 1719.
And everybody knows
this novel even
if they haven't read it, right.
It's the story of the
shipwrecked Englishman, who
creates a plantation on
an island with the help
of a colonized subject Friday.
Karl Marx called Crusoe the
ideal English homoeconomicas.
James Joyce referred to
Crusoe as the true prototype
of the English colonizer.
Edward Said agreed.
But there's so much
going on in the novel
with Crusoe's legal identity.
The very first
line of the novel,
we learn that Crusoe's
father is a German foreigner.
He's from the same
region in Germany,
in fact, that so many
of the German migrants
had come to seeking
refuge in England.
Most people skip
this observation.
But-- and this is something I've
been covered in the archives
as well-- according to
a law called the Aliens
Law of the time, Crusoe
as the son of a foreigner
would not have been able
to inherit anything.
So that gives a new
spin to the reason
why he may have left England
to seek fortune elsewhere.
And it also means that he
couldn't colonize an island
in the name of England as
Edward Said insists he does.
Later in the book-- and this
is a smaller detail that's been
neglected as well--
Crusoe takes an oath
of naturalization
so that he can buy this
plantation in Brazil, purchases
some slaves.
And so technically the entire
time he's on the island,
he is a Portuguese Catholic
subject under the law.
And so when he reclaims
all of his profits
after being rescued
from the island,
he discovers that a lot of
the profits of his plantation
have gone to supporting
the Portuguese empire.
I'm not just reading this
into the novel, I should say.
Defoe was really
aware of what he
was doing, because he
was a journalist prior
to being a novelist.
And he was one of the
biggest journalists
to write on the
Palatine refugee crisis.
In fact, he was
one of the few who
agitated to have the
Palatines settled in England.
So if you start looking
at the novel this way,
it emerges as a book
that's a warning to England
about what's going
to happen if it
doesn't settle its foreigners.
That's one reading of it.
So that's one of the
books I've re-examined.
The second is a book called
Laurence Sterne's Sentimental
Journey Through France and
Italy published in 1768.
It's one of the most famous
novels of the 18th century,
though, many of us
don't remember it today.
It was one of Thomas
Jefferson's favorite novels.
It's loosely a story
about a English man
named Yorick, who goes
over to France by sneaking
into somebody else's carriage.
And when he gets
there, he has all
of these sentimental encounters
with people that he meets.
And most scholars
read it as a satire
of bourgeois humanitarianism,
because the level
of his sentimental
encounters are a bit dubious.
They're often sexual
or overblowing.
But, again, like
Robinson Crusoe,
the novel is framed
from its very beginning
by a law about foreigners.
The very first
lines of this novel,
as well, we learn that Yorick is
subject to a bitter French law
called the Law Over Strangers,
which would stipulate
that if he died while
he was in France,
the French monarch could
take all of his property.
The Law Over
Strangers and distance
great historical work on
it by the historian Peter
[? Salends. ?] It's
more than a feudal tax.
In the time period,
it's the only way
that France has to make a
stipulation between who's
the subject of France
and who's an alien.
And so to evade it, there's
this amazing moment.
It's one of my favorite in
all of literature, I think,
where Yorick
discovers that if he's
going to evade detention and
evade the effects of this law,
he has to come up
with a passport,
but he doesn't have one.
So he discovers
that there's a shop.
And he goes in, and he
buys Shakespeare's Hamlet.
And he goes to the
count who meets out
passports for
foreigners and says,
open to the gravediggers passes.
And he says, that's me and just
points to the name, Yorick.
And it's this
really funny passage
that I can't do justice to.
Laurence Sterne is an
incredible writer where
he's not technically lying.
But the count gets
mistaken and thinks
that he's another Yorick.
So this third Yorick who's
a famous court jester.
And so the count decides
to give him his passport.
And this is an
illustration at the moment.
And then Yorick is
free to stay in Paris
and bumble around and have
more sentimental encounters.
This novel is really
ahead of its time,
I think, in asking questions
about the distinction
between private and
political identity.
And the book has a lot to
teach us about passports
before the age of biometrics,
because in the 18th century,
a passport was a florid
letter of introduction.
Someone says, oh,
yeah, I know this guy--
let him in.
There's no physical
descriptions on it.
And so it's this beautiful
interplay of language
that lets Yorick
sneak in using Hamlet
as a introduction for himself.
So that's another one.
The last one is
Frankenstein, which
is enjoying its 200th year
anniversary this year.
And the novel, as we all know,
has many interpretations.
One of the most
seminal is that it's
a warning about what will
happen if people stray too
far from their native home,
which Victor Frankenstein does
when he goes off to college.
And you start to create life
outside of the conditions
of natural birth.
And like the other
two novels, this one
has a legal political
dimension too.
I almost prefer the 1818
version of the text.
It's often considered
as the more original
or pure scholarly edition.
But in 1831, when
she revised it,
Mary Shelley changes Victor
Frankenstein's birthplace.
Instead of being a
citizen of Geneva
after the style of
Jean Jacques Rousseau,
she has him born in
Italy, and then he
becomes naturalized in Geneva.
In the 19th century, Geneva was
one of the most cosmopolitan
cities in Europe.
Even before then, it was one
of the biggest places of refuge
for the persecuted Huguenots.
But the city had a
real current of unrest
at the time of which
Mary Shelley was
aware she had written
about it in her letters.
Over time, the number of people
who could be citizens of Geneva
had grown smaller.
So in this context, Victor
Frankenstein's monster
emerges as what we might call
the ultimate unnaturalized
foreigner.
At one point, he meets a blind
old man in the countryside.
And the old man asks him
like who he is and asks him
if he's a French man.
And the monster
replies, well, French
is the only language I
speak, but I'm not French.
And so like the
sans-papiers today,
he exists within the state but
goes completely unrecognized
by it.
And I'm hoping that what I want
to do more with Frankenstein
is to attach these
kind of legal readings
to some of the
brilliant work that's
been done on the
creature's race,
because it's emphasized
repeatedly in the novel
that he's not white.
He's not European.
And so I think we
could definitely
see the novel in
conjunction to debates
about the black poor at the
end of the 18th century, who
were shipped off to a colony
rather than dealt with in law
in England.
So that's what I'm
looking at there.
There's so many more I
could tell you about.
There's this really funny
one called The Adventures
of Ferdinand Count Fathom, which
features a protagonist who's
born in a wagon that's passing
over the border of Holland
and Flanders.
And his head comes
out in Holland,
but his feet come
out in Flanders.
And in the rest of the
novel is everyone trying
to figure out where he's from.
But I won't tell you.
I'll stop there.
[LAUGHS] I'm uncovering
a different story
about the 18th century novel.
And the novels I
read show awareness
about the lives of
migrants and migration.
They show awareness about
the effect of policy and law
on identity.
And they're grappling
with scenarios
that nationality
law in its infancy
was just only
beginning to work out.
What happens if you're
born outside the country
that your parents were born in?
Can you have allegiance
to two countries?
How does your legal identity
change when you migrate?
Why do we allocate
subject heard according
to the circumstances of birth?
It seems to me that some of
the early readings of the novel
are partial selective and maybe
ignore important elements that
can help us rethink
notions of identity
and belonging that sometimes
we take for granted today.
One of the conclusions I
reached in my study of Arendt
was that Arendt thought
that each generation had
to study the conditions of
its own immigration crisis
from within its own time.
I think that's basically
right, except, I
think that if we're
going to do that,
we have to rethink the
very mythologies that
perpetuate the coupling
of nationality and birth.
And I think the
novel can help us.
It can help us rediscover
alternative, perhaps,
more inclusive
principles to relate
to those beyond the borders of
our limited national geography
and political imagination.
I also think that the
novel can shed light
on other ideas that
have been eclipsed
by the rise of the nation
state and birthright
citizenship in the
past two centuries.
At least, that's
what I'm going to be
trying to think about for the
remainder of my time here.
So I'll end with those thoughts.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]